[Music]
season two is finally here I was not
necessarily expecting to see you when
you saw that Elsie was back in the
scripts I got the call I knew the whole
time okay so but I'm very excited to be
back and thrilled to be able to talk
about it yeah
secretive this say yes very secretive
when you guys got that first script what
was your reaction to where season two
picks up I was surprised and I I was
surprised when I saw the first script
and then the second script and the third
one and the fourth one and then the
finale that's quickly yes it would it's
very very surprising that's what I hear
about this season very exciting and it's
totally surprising where do we pick up
with each of your characters I can't
tell you well I can say about Hector is
that when we last saw him on the finale
of season 1 he was willing to face this
army to give Maeve a chance to fight
escape now
yes he's back we just don't know what
condition is in similar that's all you
see Elsie somewhere in the park
we're not sure what condition she's in
but that's a choice you have in common
our characters have that in common
not sure what condition you're both all
right
what was your one big question leftover
from season one and did you get your
answer in season two I wanted to know
more about dillos I wanted to know more
about your what their endgame was and
and what was you know is essentially
what else about trying to figure it out
and I think yeah you get the answer yeah
yeah I know you do as season 2 explores
more Dallas you know the corporation
behind and and its Genesis so I think
you have those answers okay
Elsie and Bernard when we left off
Bernard kind of thought he maybe it
killed Elsie yeah he did some choking
well we see Elsie and Bernard interact
this season I mean I know that if I were
Elsie I would certainly want a little
retribution but I don't know I don't
know if she gets it and then Hector and
Maeve well we see what will we see
between them this season
hmm you guys are well trained well well
you know I that's the fun of it you you
you watch it you see but I would
definitely say that they will reconnect
and develop that connection that was
established in season one ruin it for
you know that's part of the fun of this
show is it's the one show it's the one
show on TV where we can count on
watching week to week to actually find
out if I gave you the answers you'd hate
me yeah if you had to sum up the season
with just one word what would that word
be mind-bending revolution alright can
we combine those a mind-bending
revolution sure yeah that actually works
perfectly okay what surprised you most
about this season to wrap things up I
think what's really interesting about
this show is that especially this season
we're watching humans lose all the power
and have to struggle with what that
means for them and we're watching the
hosts gain autonomy and and get to
decide who they are and I think watching
the dance of like how that story plays
out is so it's mind-bending and
fascinating and so exciting yeah as
opposed to beginning a journey of you
know self-discovery and and sort of like
an existential crisis if you will where
they're searching for their own
identities and how they're free from the
narratives that were created for them so
it will be interesting to watch what now
that they have their freedom what will
they do with it just a very casual show
about the birth of a new species
we will leave it at that no I can't go
anywhere thanks guys
[Music]
[Applause]